(mellow hip hop music)
- [Narrator] In Ghana,
coffins can look like this.
They're carved into whimsical shapes
and painted bright colors
meant to represent a
person's life or occupation.
- [Narrator] Anang and his
family are at the center
of these extravagantly designed,
larger than life coffins
made in the shape of whatever one desires.
- [Narrator] It started about 65 years ago
with an odd request from a chief
to be buried in a coffin
shaped like a cocoa pod.
From there, the requests kept coming in
and Anang's father realized he had
a serious business on his hands.
While funerals are a
sad occasion in Ghana,
many also see them as an opportunity
to celebrate the deceased.
- [Narrator] When an order comes in
for one of their coffins,
they first get the
measurements of the deceased,
carve the wood into the shape
of the family's choosing,
create an opening and
sand it for smoothness.
It then goes to an artist for painting.
Once the interior's stuffed,
it's ready to be delivered to the family.
And these coffins are not
only delivered locally.
- [Narrator] As for Anang, he
already has his picked out.